when the legal tampering period opened
on monday i pointed out time and again
that nothing is official until it's
official and some would say why do you
do that because sometimes
deals that aren't official never become
official case in point linebacker
anthony barr agreed to terms with the
jets but that was monday night the deal
can't become official until it's signed
after 4 pm eastern on wednesday
and at some point along the way
according to multiple reports barr had a
change of heart and decided not to sign
with the jets now manish meta the new
york daily news suggests that the
vikings sweetened their offer after
barr had a deal in place with the jets
which
could be regarded by some in league
circles as bad form but nothing is done
until it's done and
as one team tries to negotiate with a
player who is still technically under
contract with another team that team the
team that holds the players rights can
continue to try to sign him and can sign
him see for the vikings and bar it can
be done
immediately the jets had to wait until
wednesday after 4 pm eastern and like
frank gore a few years ago when he
changed his mind about signing with the
eagles and joined the colts instead barr
changes his mind
about joining the jets and he stays with
the team that made him the ninth overall
pick in the 2014 draft the latest young
viking who has signed a long-term deal
and will continue to be part of a
nucleus that from the vikings
perspective hopefully we'll contend into
2019 and beyond
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports